[Music]
Hello viewers, I'm Vibbuti Ja. This is
Japur Dialogue USA. Welcome to the show.
As always, as a request, please like,
subscribe, and support our channel. Give
your feedback and support any which way
you can.
A lot has happened in the last couple of
weeks if not months
and you know one of the key things is
that how you know India had operation
Synindur with Pakistan, United States
had operations hammer with Iran,
Israelis is a constant conflict with
Hamas and in Gaza and now you have
United States President Pope Mr. Trump
going to Middle East for an remarkable
uh event in which he got a gift of $400
million worth of a jumbo jet from Qatar
and commitment for investment in the US
ranging into trillions of dollars. And
now Mr. Trump is signing has signed the
waiver of sanctions that was imposed on
Syria following the handshake with the
man who had actually
led the entire fight of ISIS against
America killing as many people as you
want.
issue is very hot and today now we have
Mamani uh you know contesting for United
New York City's mayor which reminds me
of Sadi Khan the mayor in London. So
what is happening with Islam? Is the
juggernaut of Islam moving to penetrate
and take over western democracies and
democracies all over the world to talk
about this important subject matter. I
have greatest of pleasure in welcoming
two veterans and stalwarts
in this domain who have done significant
work in bringing the truth about Islam
and truth is very harsh sometimes
unpleasant and we have to deal with that
you know the the the two gentlemen are
Mr. Robert Spencer whom everybody knows
and Mr. Rahul Sur also who has been on
our show many times and he's also known
to Japur dialogue audience. Uh you know
without further ado let me straight away
dive into with Robert. Robert your take
on the issues that have engulfed the
world and the way Mr. Trump is moving
and the way Islam is moving through the
western world and I have often said you
are familiar with my phrase why is the
west and the democracies of the world
bending backwards to accommodate a faith
that has political ambition
to annihilate all of us and establish
you know what is known as uh you know
the Islamic rule all over the world
kilafat 2.0 or 3.0 Oh, Robert, your
take.
Well, thank you, my friend. It's good to
see you again. And the question you've
asked is very important, but there's no
clear answer. On the one hand, Islam is
doing what it always does. It is an
aggressive expansionist
supremacist ideology. And so, they see
their chance to move ahead and expand
their influence and power in the West.
And they're doing so. And so uh on the
one hand it's perfectly clear. On the
other hand what the president is doing
and why
it's clear in one sense and completely
opaque in another. He is of course a
businessman. He's a billionaire and he
is uh famous for making deals. He wrote
a book the art of the deal. I don't
think that there is any problem in the
world that he doesn't think can be
solved by sitting down all the
principles involved in making a deal.
And so he is even dealing now with
Asharah Ahmed Ashar the former jihadi or
supposedly former jihadi the former
al-qaeda leader who is the president of
Syria. He is making repeated overtures
even after bombing Iran's nuclear
facilities to negotiate with Iran. And I
don't think with all respect that he has
a clear or comprehensive understanding
of the political supremacist,
aggressive, violent and expansionist
aspects of Islam. and he thinks that
these are people that ultimately he can
appeal to on the basis of common shared
self-interests or pl points at which the
self-interest of the United States and
the West corresponds to the
self-interest of Syria or Iran. And that
doesn't seem to me to be wise in
discounting
the ideology and the nature and
influence of Islam in this regard. The
Muslims never forget about it. They
never act separately from it. Obviously,
I'm not talking about every single
Muslim in the world. I'm talking about
people such as Ash Sharah who has still
not demonstrated convincingly that he is
not dedicated to establishing Islamic
law. There was just the massacre in the
church in Damascus a couple of Sundays
ago that was reportedly by people linked
to his group. And there are other
indications that Islamic law is being
imposed upon Syria and jihad is being
waged against the Alawites and the
Christians. And consequently
to take his declarations of uh having
left jihad at face value, I think would
be naive. But the president doesn't seem
to have any interest in the man's past
or his possible present at all. He's
just making a deal.
making a deal. You know Rahul G you are
familiar and my audience are very
familiar with my favorite phrase
where do we go knowing what we know as
as I always say that you know one the
reason why it is critical to ask that
you know there was a cartoon just I saw
yesterday that while Iran's capability
to have nuclear weapons have been
diminished quite significantly we also
heard the story line that Iran is just
about months away from uh you know
developing enriched uranium for the
purposes that it wants it and the
cartoon was that there are three
countries still having Islamic nuclear
bomb and the countries are Pakistan, UK
and France. So my question to you would
be my friend is
what what how do you see is is the west
has the west already submitted to Islam
the way they are trying to pate a faith
that wants us dead and you know France
UK US you know what is this what's going
on considering considering the plight of
minorities
in Pakistan Bangladesh and many parts of
the world not to forget
the you know the uh uh the the one they
did it in Iraq the ISIS did to Yazi
Yazidis yes I forgot that name not to
forget what happened to them your
thoughts Rahul Gi
so first of all thank you very much
Vibbi for inviting me in the show and
I'm really honored to be with Robert
Spencer uh you know in this regard your
question I think that right now what is
happening in terms of international
affairs is of course very striking
in terms of what the United States is
doing and what the ambitions of the
United States president are and his
seemingly unwavering belief that you
know commerce and a good deal and a
handshake across the table can solve
everything. But I think we need to pause
and see exactly what has happened in the
west in terms of the infiltration of
Islam in these countries. Right now
there are various indicators. These are
objective indicators which we all need
to pay attention to because these are
not going to change irrespective of the
dramatic ups and downs of the
international situation. All right. Now
let's look at indicator number one that
is what is the increase in Muslim
population in the UK in France in
Germany and you will find that it is a
very significant growth and in terms of
projection they are in they are uh they
are believed to be in a significant
minority by the by 2015. That's
indicator one. Number two is let's have
a look at the number of mosques which
have increased after 911 which is there
in France, Germany, UK and the num
number again you have a steep increase
to the northeast.
Indicator number three is what are the
trends of participation of Muslim
politicians in the national politics and
you will find that again that is very
steeply on the rise. For instance, in
the last general election in the UK, uh
there were Muslims who had stood as
independent candidates and had won. And
given their alliance with the left, I
think that as I said, irrespective of
the effervesence and the ups and downs
of what Trump is doing and whether he
will succeed or not, which lies in the
womb of history, uh given the the
warning which Robert has has has said
that he does not seem to be very aware
of the impulses in terms of you know
wanting to conquer. uh the west is in a
pretty bad shape and consequently uh
this requires some reflection on our
part. Again, this is not Islamophobic.
All I'm saying is we have to have a look
at the uh the impartial indicators which
show that the west is in a shape where
it has a force which is highly enimical
to its values and therefore it will have
to pull up his socks and do something.
That is where I see the situation right
now with Bhuti. I don't know whether
Robert agrees with that or not.
I will definitely
request Robert to comment on your
thoughts but I will add here so that you
know Mr. Trump introduced the concept of
reciprocal tariff. It created a fur or
upset the apple cart around the world.
And I have always been saying those who
are familiar with my thought that we are
not demanding reciprocity on the
political and social conversation,
dialogue, debate or discussion with
Islamic people. So how do you see that
that if we do not demand reciprocity and
I this is what I said on an Indian
channel today that's re removing the
sanctions on Syria is great but have we
also established reciprocity that can
you
showcase that respond to the democratic
framework in a reciprocal manner? Are we
demanding that? Is is that part of the
art of deal or we are letting it go by
that you can do what you like but just
agree to what I want?
Robert, uh the
point is very well taken. The art of the
deal is what the president has said that
he's all about. And yet, where is it in
regard to Syria? In the United States,
if Muslims want to come over here and
they want to build a mosque, there's no
problem at all. Anybody who objected 20
years ago was shut down as Islamophobic.
And nowadays, it's just taken for
granted that if a Muslim group wants to
build a mosque somewhere, then there's
no problem. And often local zoning laws
are amended so that they can do this
wherever they want to. In residential
neighborhood, no problem. they changed
the laws for them. It's there many
precedents for this. Now in Syria,
meanwhile, not only was the uh prophet
Elias Greek Orthodox Church uh targeted
by jihadis linked to the regime and 25
people killed, many many others injured.
Other churches were threatened. Last
Sunday, they said there would be more
massacres and there was a whole list of
other churches. Now, it doesn't seem as
if it's happened, but what they're
trying to do is strike terror into the
enemies of Allah as the Quran directs.
And you don't even have to kill people
to do that. But it's also an indication
that jihadi forces are active in Syria.
There are numerous indications that they
do have ties to the the Shira
government. And consequently, where is
the reciprocity indeed? Why doesn't the
president make a deal on the basis of
saying you have to leave the Christians
alone? You have to allow them to
practice their faith and provide as the
government for their safety and security
in exactly the same way that American
authorities do for mosques and Muslims
in the United States. And if they want
to build new churches, you don't bother
them about it. And the Islamic law
forbids the building of new churches or
the repair of older ones. And that has
to go if you want to make a deal with
the United States. If you don't want to
make a deal with the United States,
that's fine, too. But if you do, then
you have to have a reciprocal religious
freedom with the religious freedom that
Muslims enjoy in the West. That would
seem to me to be perfectly reasonable
thing for the president to say, but it's
not even on the table. It's not even
being considered. There's nobody of any
power and influence who is suggesting
it, much less the president saying it to
Ahmed Ashar. And so, uh, unfortunately,
this puts the United States at a
disadvantage that they're are they're
negotiating from a position of weakness,
as you said, Vubi, that they just let
them do whatever they want as long as
they make a deal with the United States.
Well, that's not something that's a
tenable position in the long run,
especially in light of the human rights
situation for religious minorities in
Syria and that goes for other countries
as well. Thank you. Coming to you Rahul
Gi taking the step forward from you know
Robert's statement that we must demand
reciprocity which is not on the table.
So the question arises the the
anhilation of women, the treatment of
women and all this is happening. You
have worked with the United Nations and
you have you have done significant work
for which many people have signed the
petition that you submitted to United
Nations. Tell us something about what
what does the United Nations still say
about the problematic aspects of Islam?
Does United States United Nations also
talk about it? And what are the rights?
Where are the rights of women? One of
the significantly abused group of people
in Pakistan, Bangladesh and anywhere. We
we see the videos, chilling videos,
shameful videos of women being you know
raped so mercilessly by them.
So Vibui GI on this question of you know
what the UN documents say it is
generally not known that the United
Nations documents are a very rich source
of the real nature of Islam and the
problems which it creates. Okay. Uh they
are of course you know opposed to uh as
they should be in terms of any
stereotyping of Muslims and I completely
agree with that. But once you have a
look at the numerous publications the
United of the United Nations you find
that the problem emerges very clearly.
Let me give you you know two three
examples. One is that the United Nations
Security Council which is the highest
body uh legally for preserving
international peace and security
after every act of significant terrorism
it issues a formal condemnation.
Now and we had done an analysis of the
formal condemnations of the security
council from 2007 to 2022
and we found that it had issued them 115
times. In that 115 times there was only
one condemnation of a group which is not
Islamic and which was the attack on the
N masjid in in New Zealand if you recall
after which there was an attack in in
Sri Lanka. So therefore, United Nations
documents clearly show where is the
problem coming from. Now that's not
enough. Uh they have the United Nations
also has a sanctions list. If you and
this is available freely. It's on the
website and I was working in the UN. I
was looking looking at this issue. Uh
all the entities which are formally
sanctioned by the United Nations are
entities which have a clearly Islamic
name. There are if I start reading them
out it's going to take me 3 minutes to
read them out. Let's come to the rights
of women. It has been formally
acknowledged by the United Nations and
not and not the least by the deputy
secretary general that Muslim women face
specific problems. And this is based
upon many many publications of their
economic commission in the in Asia and
the in West Asia in which there are so
many reports which talk about violence,
domestic violence, laws of inheritance,
all that is not Islamophobic but is
right there in United Nations documents.
Now let me just read out uh for for your
for your benefit something again from a
2016 UNESCO report which is written by a
Muslim and it's a partial quotation
which says the recent history of the
peoples of Islam and its cycles of
effervesence and progress have been
conducive to the emergence of criminal
blind and in the long run ineffective
violence. Far from ensuring that Islam
is integrated in the universal human
value. this path makes it an outcast
amongst nations. End of quote. This is a
United Nations report. And therefore uh
my area of special interest is to look
at Islam from the point of view of the
normative guidelines which are contained
in UN documents and in international
treaties. And from that point of view
there is a lot to worry about. In 2024,
we had launched a formal complaint about
what Sharia how it violates women's
human rights. And I am looking forward
to Robert Spencer's book on on the same
subject November. I have already you
know booked it but I would be very happy
to give it to him so he can have a look
at the subject from the point of view
what we have found from United Nations
and the number of treaties which number
of treaties and international
conventions which it violates. So that
is how the subject looks like for based
purely upon United Nations norm. Taking
myself out of the picture, taking
anybody out of the picture, the picture
is very depressing and very concerning.
Very depressing and very concerning. And
that's what the problem lies. Robert,
you know, people like us are immediately
branded as Islamophobic.
This is a real problem. And that's where
I have that we do not have the freedom
of speech. Our freedom of speech to even
make an inquiry. Forget about
questioning or challenging even to make
an inquiry is snubbed. You use the word
terrorize. The hurdu word is
you know they impose on you and I and
individually target those people who
dare to speak out. and I'm proud to be
one of them and joining the select band
of you and Rahul Rahul G in this regard
is that we we are not afraid.
I'm talking about freedom of speech and
I said this some time ago that freedom
of speech is not about standing in a
park and speaking for three hours.
Freedom of speech is all about making
those simple inquiries when, where, who,
what, how something happened, right? And
we are not allowed that freedom of
speech. This is the institutional
element that United Nations knows what
is going on yet the world is falling
bending backwards to accommodate a faith
that openly says death to you. Your
thoughts? Well, you know, the United
Nations has an initiative against
Islamophobia,
and Islamophobia is an a term that was
invented precisely for the purpose of
inhibiting criticism of Islam and making
people ashamed and afraid to say
anything remotely critical about Islam
for fear of being branded with this term
which is equated with racism and hatred
and so on. And so I am happy to hear
that the United Nations speaks out about
various human rights abuses that are
perpetrated in Islamic countries in
accord with Islamic law. And it was even
more encouraging and quite surprising to
hear that they name Islam in at least
some of these documents.
But is it not true? And I may be very
wrong about this. So correct me if I'm
wrong please, but I am under the
impression anyway that ordinarily for
the most part when the United Nations
speaks about for example
female genital mutilation
or honor killing
or any number of other abuses of women
that are carried out in accord with
Islamic law that they very carefully
explain that this doesn't have anything
to do with Islam and that it's something
that arises from a variety of cultural
and religious
uh
impetuses that
cannot be generalized about. And so
consequently, it would be wrong, if not
Islamophobic, to identify these problems
with the Islamic community in general.
And yet when it comes to those two that
I mentioned and many others, the primary
if not the soul
foundation, the primary motivation, the
primary uh belief system from which
these things emerge is indeed Islam.
There are other groups that engage in
these practices that are not Muslim but
they are a small minority and the
practice is rejected by those groups.
Whereas in Islam there is textual
foundation for the justification for
those actions and this is what the UN
doesn't seem to be willing to
acknowledge. Am I correct in that or
not? I think you're absolutely correct,
Robert, and there is a dichotomy in
terms of what it its documents speak to
in terms of where the problem exists and
the attitude it takes towards Islam. And
let me just elaborate on that.
Your connection is lost. Rahuli,
let him come back.
Let him come back. But but we'll
continue the conversation there. But
Robert, while Rahul is rejoining us,
there is another element which is very
critical and that is the branding of you
and I and anybody who dares to make an
inquiry as Islamophobic. In reality,
there is no Islamophobia. In my opinion,
even if you quote the text, you are
branded as Islamophobic as if we are
spreading the canard. So even if we
quote the truth,
there is a fatwa against you and I.
Yeah, you're quite right. That's been
going on for years. I remember the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation,
uh, which is not coincidentally the
largest voting block at the UN today.
The Organization of Islamic Cooperation
started about 20 years ago, the
Islamophobia Observatory.
And the Islamophobia Observatory at the
OIC
chronicled supposed incidents of
Islamophobia. And I would feature in
their report every month uh quoting
imams.
And the imams were never condemned. It
was only when I quoted these imams that
this became Islamophobia. But anyway, I
see that
sorry. So the thing is that on a formal
level the position of the United Nations
is that Islam that no religion can be
associated with any no terrorism cannot
be associated with any religion or
civilization. When it comes to female
genital mutilation they they say that it
is not Islamic. The contention is that
there is something called true Islam
which applied in its true spirit would
not lead to all these problems. However,
that is the position which they take.
But their own documents
furnish a wealth of indisputable
evidence that that is not the case. For
example, let me quote another book that
is called the handbook on the management
of violent criminal extremists. Right
now, that is for people who are there.
Now, who has written that book? Who has
written the book?
That is that is the United Nations
Office of Drugs and Crime which is based
in Vienna. And I have done a thorough
analysis of that including the number of
times which it has mentioned Islam,
number of times it has mentioned
Buddhism, Janism, Sikhism, Christianity.
And therefore when one goes by the
statistical evidence which is a very
simple thing to do, uh you will find
that the only religion which is
mentioned in it is Islam. And they have
also got evidence of quotations of the
people who they try to rehabilitate in
which what were the religious
motivations. So you see you have a
Janusfaced situation in which the
position of the UN is that no it's not
nothing to do with Islam but yet at the
same time there are these gig gigantic
problems which it has to deal with. So
therefore it is not acknowledging the
reality it is a split thing and and
Robert is exactly right. My point was
that these documents furnish a very rich
trove of unexamined evidence which we
have looked at. That's the point.
Robert, I wonder if I answer your
question.
Thank you.
Go ahead, Robert. You want to say
something on this?
Well, that's a very important thing that
could be done and I uh I take it that
this is something that you have uh
started to do and I applaud you for it
that the UN has a great deal of
information and of course it has such a
great reputation even today that
information coming from the UN carries
such weight. uh information about jihad,
about the human rights abuses that are
inherent in Sharia and so on. And the
only thing it doesn't do is relate them
to the cause thereof. But that's it can
do.
Yeah.
I wanted to come to you. Uh sorry, you
were saying something.
I was saying that here is a quotation
from the 2018 report of experts on the
Democratic Republic of Congo uh to the
security council. I'm reading it out
verbatim. They within brackets the
attackers also recorded information
about each person including their name
and religion. They asked them why they
had not converted to Islam and showed
the Quran to one of them. Photos of the
dead show they had been bound and some
of them had been tied together. After
the killing they shot in the air twice
saying that they had killed all the
coffers. This is from a United Nations
report. And no matter how much of
pretending which the United Nations
does, this is there in black and white.
And consequently, what I'm suggesting to
Robert and we can talk about this later,
there is a very rich unexploited vein of
evidence which can be used for the
civilizing purposes and also for making
sure that we are abiding by the values
of the United Nations and international
human rights convention which is my load
star.
Great Robert, I wanted to talk to you
about the political element of this one.
The documentary evidence which Rahuli
has quoted from United Nations is
amazing. Uh that's what I wanted both of
you to be talking about this today. The
other part which I have I have enu
enumerated a theory which is I call a 3V
theory. The first V stands for the
moment Islam gathers a you know sizable
element in a democratic setup where vote
matters. So there's a vote bank politics
they indulge it absolutely with a with a
you know all kinds of constitutional
rights. They they they indulge in
violence virtually at the drop of a hat.
You say anything they indulge in street
violence and then they also claim
victimhood
for everything. Robert Rahul Vivoti is
responsible for their plight. How does
one address that? All three things the
3V tactical approach that they have
adopted is working for them using
democratic tools and thus I coined the
phrase they have completely figured out
that the freedom can be used as the
fault line of democracy. Your thoughts
on this? The first thing the vote bank
politics has to be confronted on the
basis of saying and trying to alert the
public to the fact that Muslims don't
need to have a majority to take over.
They are because Islam is inherently
political. Whenever they come to a new
land, they seek political power. And you
may have Muslims being in a small
minority and yet over represented in the
local government because this is a
primary objective whenever they settle
in a new land and there is virtually no
awareness of this in the west or
anywhere else in the non-Muslim world.
And so the first thing that we have to
do is emphasize this to the point where
it becomes common knowledge. I remember
and this can be done. I remember 25
years ago,
nobody had heard of, for example, takia,
the deception in Islamic law that is
allowed that you deceive the
unbelievers. And Muhammad said war is
deceit and so on. And after 911, I
started talking about it. Other people
started talking about it. And now I see
on X on Twitter uh ordinary people who
don't have never studied Islam. They
have heard of this term. They are aware
of this as a possibility as we wish that
the president were right now that he
might be being deceived by these Islamic
entities. Uh but this is an indication
of the fact that it is possible if we
keep pushing and we keep emphasizing
these facts that we can bring them to
general awareness. And so that would be
the first thing that Islam is political
that it is supremacist that they will
always seek political power and that
non-Muslim communities have to be
prepared for that and may be ready to
ask candidates like this Mam Dani who's
about to become mayor of New York. Ask
him if he is part of an organized
Islamic effort and what does he say
about such an organized Islamic effort
to gain political power. uh and what
does it portend for non-Muslims
particularly those that are targeted
for a special hatred and vilification
you know for example chapter 5 vers 82
of the Quran says that the strongest
enmity to the believers are the Jews and
the polytheists
and so every Muslim politician in the
United States should be confronted if he
shows that he is a devout and
knowledgeable believer with the
question, what do you what do you intend
to do with Jews and Hindus in your
administration?
And do you believe that they are enemy
natural enemies of your religious
community? And consequently, how will
that fact inform your actions in office?
Nobody would dare ask in the first
place. They don't know to ask it because
they don't know anything about Islam.
But also no journalists would dare to
ask these politicians such questions.
But those are the questions that have to
be asked them. If they won't no if the
or journalists now won't ask them then
we have to get into journalistic uh
establishments and get into a position
where we can ask
very valid question and very valid
thought and I also wanted to talk about
another thing which is their their
pattern. they immediately become
victims.
Everybody is responsible for their
suffering and their plight. They are not
themselves.
And that brings to the other aspect
which I wanted to ask you that you know
everybody is talking about it now thanks
to social media and the spread of
technology the way it has happened.
People are now asking how is it that
Keith Starmer and France everybody is
embracing they are talking about
bringing uh Gaza people to the to their
country democracies but no Islamic
country ever wants them. It's a very
interesting issue. The migration the
refugee crisis is because the Islamic
countries don't take them. Rahul Gi,
your thought on this as well as Robert's
thought on it. So whoever wants to go
first please be my guest.
So
so I'll go to uh Robert may I
please?
Yes. So you know in first uh let's look
at this specific aspect which you
propose which you talked about that is
migration. Right. Now I think that we
have to step back a little bit and see
uh the weaponization of the word
Islamophobia.
The word has the word is both a sword
and a shield. It has silenced people. It
has destroyed careers. It has put people
into a very very active self
selfcensorship mode. And the first thing
I think we need to do when we talking
about issues any issue which is
connected to Islam is to have a look at
the word Islamophobia
and understand that it is a word which
has become so well accepted that we need
to find a different word to counter it.
And my solution to this, I've been
thinking about this and my solution is
to come up with an alternative word,
word against word. And that word is
islamoactism.
A person who practices talking about
Islam and Muslims based on facts is an
Islamopactist. And right now I am in the
process of publishing a 10-p part series
on this issue which is a fictitious
conversation between a European Union
bureaucrat and an Islamopactist on all
these issues which are the hot button
issues concerning Islam. you know what
is Muslimness uh Muslim identity women
crime terrorism integration and
therefore this has been published in in
uh eight parts have been published
already and one of the issues in which I
look at looked at in that is integration
right there is a there's a conversation
that so there are hard indicators which
we can see in terms of migration in
which they have not integrated into
western societies which comes from the
Quranic injunction that they will not be
friends with unbelievers which accounts
for the fact that they always try to
separate themselves and it essentially
it requires a fact-based and a you know
courageous approach. But the problem is
that electoral politics intervenes and
since their voters are blocked, it is
very attractive for these countries and
their leadership and very difficult for
them to turn it down in a short of a
mass and you know increase in awareness
and political pressure on these people.
Again I say I'm very concerned about
this because these are issues which are
going to only keep on increasing unless
we deal with them factually squarely and
on the basis of an Islamopactist
approach.
Thank you. I wanted to add Robert coming
to you on this. You know I have always
wondered and I have said this many times
you know like what is it about the
western democracies and democracies of
the world that we bend backwards to
accommodate appease pander to a faith
that wants us dead. I mean let's not
mince words on it. They want us dead.
The question here is I found the answer
to to give credit to Douglas Murray who
wrote coined the word since you said
Islamopactist.
He came up with the word Islamophilia.
So the question is
taking into account Mamdani's rise in
the New York mayoral poll which is still
in November and you know he has
fortunately fortunately for the rest of
the world I would put it that there is
Eric Adams sitting mayor who is fighting
as an independent having left democratic
party how do you account for that part
that how the west must deal with it we
must talk about certain solutions if
possible problem we know let's talk
about some possible solutions to that.
Robert,
certainly true. We have to be realistic
about the issue, but as you noted, the
whole Islamophobia agenda is designed to
inhibit and silence any realistic
discussion about Islam. And it works
wonderfully. You know, I see routinely
local officials all over the United
States and somebody dares to say
something negative about Islam and then
the Council on American Islamic
Relations denounces the the poor
official and calls for his resignation.
And the level of ignorance about the
issue is so great that the usually he
has to resign and it's represented as if
he said something egregious or usher
issued a racial slur or something of
that kind. And nothing is that's not the
case. He was only speaking realistically
and honestly about Islamic doctrine, but
it's been so stigmatized now. And so
what we have to have are enough people
who are willing to brave the stigma and
to keep speaking the truth. And the more
that there are, the less it will be
possible for them to stigmatize and
silence us. You know, you have pointed
out that you and I or all three of us
here and many others have indeed been
stigmatized and marginalized by the
mainstream for daring to speak about
Islam realistically. And this is in
accord with tactics that the left
devised. and Saul Alolinsky in
particular, the author of Rules for
Radicals. And he was a a Marxist
propagandist in the middle of the 20th
century who wrote this book about how to
win the left, win the West for the left.
And one of his rules is that you destroy
your opposition one by one.
you isolate a target and vilify this
person and freeze them out and then make
everybody else
have to answer for why they associated
with him. Like if I said to if I did it
to you and I said vibi he's a racist
bigoted Islamophobe and so we should
have nothing to do with him. And then I
go to Rahul after I've done that and I
say, "Why? How can you explain that you
appeared on a show with with Vibbouti,
the well-known racist, bigoted
Islamophobe, and put you on the
defensive, and then you have to explain,
and you're destroyed for the
association, and then the next person,
and everyone is destroyed one by one,
often just simply by association. So if
there are so many of us that this cannot
be done then we might start making
progress but unfortunately up to now
it's been quite effective because people
see what happens to us and they don't
want to be in that situation so they
keep quiet which is exactly the
objective
and they did it to Nupush Sharma in
India which is a well-known case.
Exactly. They do it to they cut the
throat of many people in the process and
you know I mean I think we are daring
enough to uh to stand up and be counted
and let the tribe expand that's what is
essential and today you know we have
many opportunities through the social
media and technology to do that Rahi
I'll come to you about a show that we
did a conversation that we had you know
we have talked about Islamop baptism we
have talked about islamophobia we have
mentioned about Islamophilia
there was a word we talked about
Islamostat
tell us let's remind the viewers once
again because we need to talk about
these matters is
so basically you see I think the
attempts have to be made to defeat them
also or confront them in the linguistic
terrain uh because that is a very
important linguist terrain which is
which can be decisive and we know ever
since you know 1984 how important it is
and how you know language can be
manipulated for aggressive ends and that
is what you know islamophobia is so one
word of course is islamopactism the
other word which I have coined is called
islamostat now what is islamostat
islamostat is a word which is derived
from the thermostat which obviously
tells the temperature and this ca this
case it is a very simple 0 to10 scale in
which the more compliant with the
literal Sharia injunctions the country
is the higher it is on the Islamist
scale in other words you know
Afghanistan will be let us say around
eight of course they still have to start
amputating amputating you know hands and
uh banning music and things like that to
achieve a 10 that's not possible but at
the same time a country which is more
liberal for instance today I see that
Kazakhstan has banned face whales so in
that sense it's Islam Islamostat is
going down. Now one can say that the
Islamostat of Saudi Arabia is tending
down whereas the Islamostat of
Bangladesh is going up. This is because
we need to give people a very simple way
of understanding a very complex
phenomenon in which there are you know
many many you have to read many many
books to see where is a country in terms
of its application of Islam Islamic
rigor. So if you disagregate it in terms
of the rights of women, minorities,
freedom, a democracy, you come across a
very simple 0 to10 figure and that is
Islam stat. So I would like to uh humbly
suggest to to Robert and to you and to
your audience to popularize these two
terms islamopactism and islamostat as
easy means of understanding a complex
subject.
Truth is the buzzword that you refer to.
Let's talk about the truth. Let's not
fear truth. Let's embrace truth. And
that's the reason why people say truth
is harsh. Truth is bitter. But we also
have a Sanskrit saying, Robert, for your
information, it says satya priya. So
even if you have to tell the truth, say
it nicely.
So have we crossed the threshold of
being nice? You know how long can you
pretend to be nice? You know, we can't
do a taka.
So, well, they can do a taka. We can't
do a taka. So, Robert, Mumbani election
possibilities of taking over New York is
high.
Uh the guy is running an AOC kind of a
campaign that AOC ran against the top
democratic leader whom she defeated. The
element which is very critical and very
interesting for us because we belong to
India. A lot of non-Indians may not know
about it. The promise of things free to
the electorate right AOC did so does so
does the entire left democratic party
does promise things for free and which
is not terrible. The same script was
used by Congress party in India. The
entire UPA opposition and Arvind Krial
the former CM of Delhi was notorious for
offering things free. Other than
offering free air to breathe, he was
promising free for everything on the ple
the planet earth. How does New Yorker
which is supposedly more educated, more
understanding of things? Because New
York also elected two remarkable
Republicans as New York mayor. Giuliani
who I've seen turn around New York
because I came here the day he became
the mayor kind of thing. a day when I
say days euphemistically speaking around
changed New York from what hell hole it
was and I have seen it myself to what it
was to Bloomberg. So I would not
underestimate the entire scenario in New
York. Thankfully for New York that Eric
Adams is in the race and Eric Adams has
migrated from being a Republican to
Democrat to to becoming independent now
and he's contesting that election you
know independently had he withdrawn from
the race completely it was a shin for
Mamani but not now because now onwards
people will get to know Mamani and
connection with the ideology that he
repres represents or he doesn't respect
doesn't respect. So accept it or deny
it. You can't be doing riding the two
boats at the same time. Where do you see
this heading on to
Robert?
Well, the prospect of the free material
is something that is probably going to
get him a lot of votes. And so the best
way to counter it here again is by
speaking about it accurately and
honestly. If I were running Eric Adams
campaign, I would get video of ordinary
New Yorkers saying, "I will have to
spend
x amount of dollars to pay for
mom donny's free grocery stores. I will
have to spend x amount of dollars based
on the tax rates, based on the estimated
tax rates and the estimated cost of this
thing." and hammer it in that nothing is
really free and that people will have to
be paid and that the working people in
New York are going to have to pay for
the free grocery stores. So, uh it's not
really free at all. I don't know if
Adams is going to do that because he is
not that far from the same socialist
principles that Mam Dani represents. But
we can hope.
We can hope Rahul gi in terms of Mandani
kind of a thing because if
New York becomes under Mamani rule, I
shudder to think what's going to happen
to this city.
I do shudder to think and I dare say
that.
However, there is a very interesting
thing in the Democratic party. Bill
Clinton, Barack Obama who have collected
millions of dollars in speeches from
many, you know, countries. they will
come endorsing him and the entire
Democratic party machinery will try to
make sure that happens.
Yeah.
How must a New Yorker respond
considering what Rahu Roberts said that
hey where is it going to come from?
Because my pet theme is which I read in
a book called illusions very aptly
titled it's so easy to promise to give
what you don't have or you don't have
to.
So I think the situation in New York is
very difficult
because I don't think that abstract
arguments are going to cut it with New
Yorkers who have this need what they
feel of a more equit quote unquote
equitable distribution of things and
it's a very simplistic situation to say
a has a lot more than he or she needs so
therefore he should give it and
therefore the problem is solved but you
know if it was that simple then you can
give you know any amount of money to
everybody and there would be there would
be no problem. Now there are two aspects
to this. One of course is the sheer
political aspect of it in terms of you
know what he has not said about
globalizing inifada. The absolutely
verifiable lies which he has told about
uh about Indian gujati Muslims not being
there. Now those are likely to be
peripheral but at the same time they can
exercise the mind of the democratic
elites who are trying to put you know
put pressure in him to walk away from
the statements and so he's a young and
charismatic guy. Uh the New York many
New Yorkers feel as if there has a need
for some change and consequently you can
ride a wave of change to anything. But
at the same time I think that uh camp a
campaign of civic engagement needs to be
mounted in terms of what has happened in
other countries in other cities where
this has been tried and this will have
to be done by the young people whom is
seducing in such large numbers. So it's
a very complex situation in which a city
which is you know always the left of
center and you have left of center and
the left of that. So there is an
internal tension which is going on and I
really don't know how it's going to turn
out but it's going to be very tough.
It's going to be very tough. But here is
the important part. My I'm an
encouragable optimist. I believe that
New Yorkers will see the the light and
the reality for the simple reason that
Mamani has no track record on which he's
running.
He's only the only thing that he can
back up with is his statements and
policies. So like for example all both
of you pointed out he has not condemned
his call for global inifa and even a CNN
veteran TV guy Jewish guy was very upset
about that what inif means for Jewish
people. Number two is the fact that he
has openly said white people will have
to pay more taxes to cover the costs of
this one. He made a reference to white
people, right? White have to pay. And
the the these are things which are very
tricky. He can't get away with that.
How will how must Adam campaign
capitalize on that part and the free
free free people are becoming more
aware. I have seen Instagram posts of
people who saying that hey I supported
AOC because I loved the idea of free
that was 10 years ago I was young and
impressionable I'm 32 now I see the lie
in it so how does if you were the
adviser to Eric Adams how must he run
that campaign against this man who has
no track record and only baloney to talk
me or
yes yes yes Robert you
the uh Adams campaign like I said they
should be hitting the practical cost as
Rahul also said the practical cost of
the free stuff so that people realize
it's not really free at all and they
have to pay for it and as for the the
white people have to pay more well there
are a few in in New York and he's
talking about having the white
neighborhoods the wealthy neighborhoods
in in Midtown Manhattan pay for pay more
in taxes and so on. And so that also can
be turned around and used against him
that these people who are providing
businesses that give jobs to New Yorkers
that allow for New Yorkers to have a
living that he's going to drive them out
and then what will be left? who where
who will employ all the unemployed New
Yorkers that he expected these rich
people to pay for? And you know there
needs to be countereducation. The left
has been educating the the general
public without challenge for decades and
giving them the idea that if you're
rich, it's because you've stolen from
someone who's poor. And they never talk
about well some people may work harder,
some people may be smarter, some people
may be luckier than others and they
amass a fortune and this is not their
fault. This is not a crime because often
they start something that employs people
and if you don't have those people I
can't afford, you know, I can't start a
business. I don't have the money and if
you don't have the businesses you don't
have jobs and why most people would not
be able to explain these very simple
principles and that's a failure of the
educational system in the US and this is
where we need to attack and explain in
very simple ways to New Yorkers and to
the whole country why this system won't
work everybody will leave New York who
has any money and Katy Matitis John
Katsy Matitis the uh grocery store
billionaire. He's already said he's
leaving and others are going to leave.
The only way socialist states in the
past have have have ex continued to
exist is because they build a wall
around to keep the people in. So then
they have to pay. And New York can't
build a wall because it's not a separate
country. So the whole everybody's going
to leave except the people who are poor
and not working and then it's just going
to get worse for them.
You know I just wanted to make that
statement so that you can also address
that he also has said in an interview
that United States should not have
billionaires should not have
billionaires. I think you know I have
always said that no immigrant comes to
America to remain poor. They come to
America to prosper. Whether prosperity
relates to career progression or
business progression or becoming wealthy
that's what America is dream is all
about yes
you can afford a life of comfort luxury
comes later
to the hardworking or to lucky luxury
comes later you know those things come
later but to categorically say that
being a billionaire is a crime and
United States should not have should is
critical
should not have billionaires Part of me
I'll I'll stop because I we we need to
hear from Rahul. But just one more thing
to say that there should not be
billionaires is to destroy the whole
incentive of working hard. And if if if
see if I wanted to be a billionaire, I
could start a business and work hard and
and build it up. And anybody can do
this. And yet he's saying at a certain
point, we're going to stop you and you
can't make any more money after this. So
then I think, why should I work hard?
Why should I bother? He's just going to
confiscate it. And so this destroys
human initiative and will destroy the
economy in the long run.
So I think that uh you know, if I was uh
advising Eric Adams, I would say that
you know, concentrate on three points.
One is get young people who have
actually lived through the situation
where they have encountered deception as
a result of the free policies and go
against that. That is number one. Number
two is it is very clear that he is a
divider not a uniter. Otherwise there
would not have been so much of outrage
about his statement. So therefore he
needs to be pointed out as a divider.
Number three is the outright false
statements that he has made in terms of
especially in terms of you know of India
and the fact that he is taking advantage
of his Indian roots to pedal lies you
know about India. So therefore you will
have to establish you will have to
recognize that there is a need for
change. You know I was talking to you
know someone in my building today and he
said well it's good you know it it mean
the people want change. That's what the
people at the bottom are telling me. So
we cannot shut our eyes to this aspect
of his campaign, but at the same time
hammer in the facts, hammer him in the
fact that he is a divisive person and
call out his lies and talk and talk and
talk because I think the message is
going to come through and I think that
the counter movement has already
started. The outrage has already
started. I can see uncomfortable people
in the Democratic party that is only
going to increase. And let us not you
know forget that it was less than 30% of
the people who voted in the Democratic
primary. So this cannot so therefore
there is a great opportunity for
increasing electoral participation also.
Thank you both of you. It has been a
fascinating conversation. I enjoyed it.
I hope you did too and so do the viewers
because there is a lesson in everything
you know uh because if you don't
participate in the political process
things don't move and the and the and
you know you don't want to end up being
a gullible compliant or taken in by the
political rhetoric of the candidates.
This is important. What you will see
more and more going forward is that you
know this is something very interesting
which I read the epic cities in Texas
for example when it was objected to and
people got to know of it. It was
fascinating to hear the Islamic lawyer
talk about the fact we are doing
everything according to US laws freedom
of religion. If you do not allow me to
live within my own confines or give me
the liberty to live the way I want to
live that means you are declaring us as
secondclass citizen. It was a master
stroke in creating a victimhood thing in
our minds. But reality was what they
were trying to create their own ghettos
or own territories where their own laws
will apply not the laws of the country
and that's what is important to
confront. Right on. Gentlemen, Robert
Spencer, Rahulsur, both of you, thank
you so much for coming on the show
today. It has been remarkably
enlightening and I hope viewers will
recognize I always end my shows with a
call to Satya Vijay, which means truth
must triumph. And for truth to triumph,
you and I will have to stand up for it.
Thank you very much. Thank you. Namaste.
[Music]